[Music]
[Applause]
13 years ago it was my freshman year of
college
2006 and I was attending my first
meeting of the Association of black
Harvard women I was so excited to meet
fellow black women classmates for the
first time we went around in a circle
introducing ourselves the first woman to
go happen to have a Nigerian name she
said hi my name is adora East Cunanan a
it means a child who is one of the
community who was given to all and whom
almost looked after then the second girl
went she said hi my name is Saran
al-azhar it means a sacred flower one
found in the Bible that is especially
sacred then it was my turn I said hi my
name is Mercedes vent it means well it's
kind of just like the car that moment
seeded a curiosity in me about African
names
I was so interest interested in the
beauty of the names 12 years later I
would find myself leading a trip to
Ghana Nigeria with Stanford and Harvard
classmates where we were going to
explore our heritage and our roots I
call head started calling the trip my
black birthright when I think back on
what inspired me to plan such a trip I
think back to that day my freshman year
of college into two other times the
second time was my was also in college
when I first learned about the Jewish
birthright or Taglit birthright Israel
trip my friends in college told me about
this all-expenses-paid trip where they
got to go visit Israel learn about their
heritage connect to their people and get
really undocked Rene de Dinh what it
meant to be Jewish I was like that's so
cool why don't we have that
the third incident that inspired the
trip was a few years later when I was in
the working world
it was 2016 and I was sitting at my desk
one day when my phone and computer
started blowing up with notifications I
clicked on a link and what I saw next
horrified me there was a video streaming
on Facebook live of a man who had just
been shot his fiancee or a girlfriend
was sitting next to him in the side seat
was filming the aftermath her
four-year-old daughter was in the
backseat
they had just he had just been shot
after being pulled over by the police on
a routine traffic stop and had been shot
about seven times and 40 seconds my mind
started racing
I started thinking why did someone shoot
into the car so quickly right after a
routine traffic stop
why would someone shoot into the car was
there there was a little girl in the
backseat
what if it had been my dad or brother
and the front seat what if I had been
the little girl in the back his name was
Phil and Oh Castel that was an incident
that jolted me very deeply the rest of
the day at work I tried to focus on
getting things done and being productive
- member of the team but unfortunately
my teammates didn't get anything from me
the rest of the day I couldn't focus
later that week I called my friend and I
said we've got to do something we've got
to help black people we looked into how
we could support economic empowerment
initiatives or how we could support
black lives matter we donated in rally
but nothing quite stuck we were still
yearning to do more it would take
another two years before I found a
solution that did stick and it ended up
being my trip to Ghana and Nigeria I
didn't realize it at the time that it
would become a solution but it did end
up being one in a way the trip itself
was full of new and exciting adventures
we went to concerts where we danced all
night - afro beats I learned how to cook
jollof rice a dish that is a staple of
African diets and has inspired intense
rivalry I got my hair braided we
discussed Nigerian politics and history
and I even got a new name so I
participated in a traditional Nigerian
naming ceremony where they gave me a
name as Sosa Ottawa ole okay as Sosa
means God's gift
Ottawa means born on a Monday and all
okay is the family name they said to me
you will always have a family here in
Nigeria welcome to the family for the
first time in my life I felt a surge of
gratitude and appreciation as I realized
I finally felt connected to the people
of the African continent to my people
over the course of the trip I realized
that my mind was really being put at
ease that the recurring racial
soundtracked caused by microaggressions
in the United States was starting to
lessen that I was healing mentally that
I was healing through heritage over the
course of the trip I also thought about
well you know what if I lived here in
Ghana or in Nigeria I wouldn't be
subjected to as many racially charged
microaggressions and I wouldn't have to
wonder if I was hired for my token or
for my potential research shows that the
development of the ethnic and racial
identity can have really positive
benefits for minorities youth and young
adults these positive benefits can
include higher self esteem greater
confidence and even higher academic
achievement in school research has also
shown that in interventions rooted in
indigenous traditions have had the
I had had the effect of decreasing
substance abuse and attempts at suicide
so what I'm talking about here the
developing and ethnic and racial
identity and connecting to your heritage
is not just a matter of having higher
self esteem or having greater confidence
although those could be great benefits
it could be a matter of life or death I
strongly believe that anybody any
displaced person who has been displaced
or up whether due to fling for a new
country or simply emigrating for a
better life can benefit from planning
their own birth rate trip and finding
some of the healing that I did so where
do I go from here i as I said thought
about you know if I lived in the night
Ghana Nigeria some of the healing
benefits I would get but if I lived
there I want to get to live here in the
United States where we have the greatest
melting pot experiment going on that the
world's ever seen
call me an optimist but I still share
Martin Luther King's dream that one day
we won't be judged by the color of our
skin I'm committed to helping more young
adults more youth of minoritized
backgrounds go on trips that such as the
one as I did I've gotten involved with
an organization called birthright Africa
and I'm hoping that together we can help
them raise money to send more people on
these trips I hope that in sharing my
story today with you guys my short story
of the healing that I went through that
you're either inspired to go find your
own birthright or support those of us on
this journey thank you
[Applause]
[Music]